Three years ago.
You win the Emmy
for best actor in a drama
for the show pose.
Yes, and here you are as pride to L.A.
fashion designer
who goes back to your home in Pittsburgh
to share some shattering news
with your family. Here you are.
I have eight
I'm dying
I have been
HIV positive for six years,
and I didn't want to burden y'all
until it became serious.
I know that we've already been through
so much.
Mommy, I'm not trying to upset you.
And I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry.
Mommy.
What?
I find
you're affected
watching that, aren't you?
Yeah.
Was that close to real life?
You know, life imitates art.
I want to talk about that,
because what I find so compelling
and so powerful about your entire story
is that you built your success
out of so much pain. Yeah.
My art
is my healer.
Art saved my life,
and I've dedicated my life
to hopefully
standing at the intersection
of
art
as a healer for trauma.
Which brings us to
your memoir, Unprotected,
which is just out in paperback
and I want to read
something from the Prolog,
the very first page of this book
you write.
By the time I was five
it was all too clear
that something was wrong with me.
Everyone knew it and I knew it, too.
Philly.
What did you think was wrong with you
and how did the world let you know
at the age of five?
Well, I didn't really have a language
for it.
In retrospect, it was my gayness.
In retrospect, I was a sissy.
I grew up in the Pentecostal church
and my family saw that behavior
and
they weren't happy with it.
And like many of us queer kids,
it's from fear,
right to behavior of our caregivers.
They're scared.
They fear for us.
I have to say,
I almost
cried at this point
because then
after feeling this tremendous
and you say you couldn't
put it into words,
this tremendous sense of being different,
of being wrong, as you say,
your mom marries your stepfather,
and your stepfather
seems to take you under his wing
and he's going to protect you
and he's going to teach you
what it is to be a man
until at the age of seven, he starts
sexually abusing you.
And I found that so painful
because I thought this little boy,
seven year old Billy Porter,
he just can't find a safe haven
There was no safety for me.
I was sent to a psychologist
when I was five for a year.
Every Wednesday after kindergarten,
because of my sexiness.
And at the end of that evaluation,
this man said in front of me,
Billy, fine,
you just need to get a man around
the house
who will teach him to be more than half.
So within a year,
my mother had met and married
my stepfather.
And when the abuse started,
there was nothing violent about it.
You know, people talk about grooming
I was very groomed.
I felt very loved.
I felt very sane.
And because of
what I had already gone through,
my little seven year
old mind thought, oh, well,
these are my man lessons.
When he's abusing it.
I didn't know that it was abuse till I
was 25 years old.
I couldn't say the words
that it was sexual abuse
until I was in therapy at 25 years old.
And my therapist said,
That's sexual abuse.
And so for years
I experienced that
because when I said
I wanted to stop at 12, it stopped.
Right.
So I experienced
that as if I had control over it.
And that it was my choice.
And of course it wasn't.
No, it wasn't.
You think you found your safe
space in the nineties
when you got into theater?
But even there you say, I was too black,
too gay, too much.
In 1997 you released an album
in which you play a traditional
male role.
And I love it, you say, which I play.
I love.
Well, I love it because it's written.
Well, okay.
But this is what I was worried about.
I was going to say words
and I wouldn't understand.
Oh, it's absolutely true.
Keep going.
All right, let's.
Let's play,
because here you are
in a video from the album
This is the song.
Oh, I love this show. Macho Man Standing
Guy
and maybe
laughing
Well, okay, now I can say you're playing.
Yes.
Heterosexual suggests that all R&B man.
Yes, I am.
Why did you make.
And I was good at it, too.
Let me just say that. Yes, you were.
Because they made me feel like
I wasn't right.
My queerness was the only thing
that anybody was interested in.
My voice was my savior
for the entirety of my life
until I got a record contract.
Why did you make that video?
Because that was the nineties
I really thought
that the only way
for me to be successful
would be to
play the game
and do what they told me to do.
And
what came out of that.
And what changed the trajectory
of my journey forever is
that I
did everything I was supposed to do.
I did everything I was told to do.
I was as straight as I could be.
I sang the music that I was supposed to.
I showed up in the way
that I was supposed to,
and I failed anyway.
And at the end of that journey,
when it all imploded,
I thought there is nothing worse
than failing as somebody else.